how's it going bros my name is beard
welcome to turrets mansion a managed
walk out of bed oh hello hello hello
pity how are you doing I did you have a
night's sleep
yeah I was pretty good so fine I can't
believe we met so early
yeah we had a lot of fun yesterday man
me inside the Nam man I should I know
I'm offending a lot of people calling
him that I just think it's funny
for some reason hello no okay I'll do it
I won't do it but I don't trust you
that's one thing's for sure and okay but
are you ready to go sip on it hell yeah
let's go oh it's the clay edition oh
whatever
what are you talking about clay edition
is just as good look at my house it's
beautiful Wow oh wow big paintings thing
you do this to follow I trust any of you
I don't trust you either
Peter doesn't trust you oh wow
that's going here just fine I can't
really know it's downstairs and it's
already unloading man the door has been
rusted damage maybe there's some oil to
grease it up have you seen some models
to follow have you know maybe it's in
here yes I think it's in here okay
man uh just yet Adam let's check it out
yeah what's the following just
[Music]
untrustable you I can trust
thank you pity you should know that you
can oh man oh the freaking of trusted
himself that's never good
never good when they entrust himself
this way yeah
let's blanket wait freakin dfrac am I
going I don't even know uh okay
bad things over there barrels whatever I
write well Wow so final get away from
the barrels I don't want you talking to
him okay let's go but I heard noises
away so be careful I don't trust you I
don't trust you da man you're such a
brahmana okay let's go here oh [ __ ] I
hate corridors you can never trust them
ever never trust them corridors ever
oh I don't want to be patients I wanna
be major are you [ __ ] kidding me be
patient
suck my dick what oh man oh man oh man
oh man oh man oh man oh man oh man oh
man oh man oh man oh man oh
break any black man if I know help me
help me oh oh I have oil well good oh oh
[ __ ] he's so [ __ ] quick okay we can
search this out bro we can sort this out
oh man
be patient are you [ __ ] kidding me
I thought we sherry was a [ __ ] but it
didn't prove it
oh I don't even have Stephano come oh
right right be patient what the [ __ ] man
ah no not just in childhood we're right
back
well rather rare very where's follow
are you kidding me oh man so bad
okay be patient be [ __ ] [ __ ] suck my
dick really
where's the phone oh okay if I click
this I am patient okay look at page them
lie that I know I'm nothing even looking
at the time oh [ __ ] oh I am patient ah
it's ridiculous be patient are you
[ __ ] kidding me he's so fast
oh come be patient what the [ __ ] man oh
I know I freaky now sure no actually I
don't know but seriously though sure I'm
taking you with me okay a shock a pity
I'm coming with you
I'm a bro so that's okay
okay seriously though I have a plan with
you mr. Sher what a plan huh [ __ ]
gets me every time
tell me brother found pity no you're not
you're not seriously gonna use me as a
seal or something please
that's pity I'm serious hey how much I
may be a share but I'm I can break I
don't wanna break I'm a fan
damn fine chair I know you're a damn
fine chair but I need your help mr.
sheriff I seriously need your help okay
I'll do this one for you baby
all because I bro but okay we need more
thing up barrels I hate to say this but
we needed to cooperate to make this work
mr. barrels
mr. barrel I want you to know that I
[ __ ] hate you but we're gonna do it
together anyway mr. barrels okay no I
can pick these up I come out I'll block
my way maybe I can you see Stan it's
clock thingy
I can definitely use these [ __ ] this guy
he's such a bad idea okay okay but I'm
taking mr. share with me in case
something happen and I should call this
door
you should put barrels there barricade
the [ __ ] out of that place
hey I want you to know I had your
barrels but you're gonna do some good
maybe I'll give you some bonus points
okay mr. chair may be ready for this I'm
not gonna lie Peter I'm pretty nervous
I know sheriff's can wet themself but if
they could I would wet myself right now
okay okay in three okay are you ready
I'm ready let's do this for beauty okay
ah [ __ ] he comes through anyway the
barrels did nothing okay take em lock in
mr. chair it's working and swag a big
hug okay okay haha buggy gotcha okay
okay I'll block this one I'll block this
one mr. Jack
ah man mr. okay one last trial this
[ __ ] demo and then we'll see you back
oh okay Oh should I bring this a share
he did a pretty fine job
oh man pity I'm sorry that you died I
really cried much too bad for you I know
it's gem Friday thank you
ah man huh so okay okay let's go in here
huh oh man it gives me every [ __ ]
time
stop untrusting yourself I still don't
trust you doesn't work it's too late to
apologize
[Music]
it's too late to put your hands barrels
barrel be patient
ah there's two mr. Xiang
okay I'm not oh go go go go go go go
okay we're good hello mr. Sherr please
tell me all your secrets
pity what the [ __ ] are you doing here
you get out of here [ __ ] so that's how
you did it oh [ __ ] you're still here oh
all right I'm just gettin it up food it
up and read it up into earlier you get
big it all back oh man I hate this
[ __ ] bat well others you find me
oh man oh man oh man
okay I'm gonna finish this [ __ ] demo
if the last thing I'd go - being out
okay I'm actually remember that around
that at this time so yes you are trust
yourself you [ __ ]
untrust away I don't trust it doesn't
mean I didn't doesn't matter how many
trying times the untrusted shell I
really know I'm here okay
what is its fifth autumn stewardess be
patient [ __ ] patient
suck my dick be patient okay
okay good good good we got it we got it
don't worry no problem soprano what are
you doing at payday I try to help you
but I sent the chatter since I will see
you thank you so much it's good again
yeah I don't trust yay we got Latin Anna
bad bout madman batter
that's pretty cozy I wish I'd my lantern
though mr. Sher you know what we should
do
sivanna plus mr. Sher there we go there
we go I'm taking you both winning Wow
new adventure to expand on mr. chair
okay that won't work
this is I preferred in the share was
guess the finals always hurt my throat
I'm not gonna lie I mean what do you
mean it has theorized it's vibe it's
what are you talking about that's super
confused okay eyes leaning now good
I'm leaving in there sitanagar we need
to find what gold in addition I'm taking
you with me
Allah pity I am cold in addition ok gold
in addition the friggin Savannah we need
to find the key or something sorry
there we go third times count okay but
seriously though why am I supposed to go
I don't understand oh maybe it's in here
I think it's sorry for dropping you the
[ __ ] oh man oh we got the grease when
you have to grease I let's go Stephano
let's get the [ __ ] out of this place
nada trust you I don't trust you either
[Music]
Triceratops wrecked our weapon as I'm
[ __ ] deaf rock stars wine synthetic
wigs made of hand wash
oh man